are you gonna wear those sunglasses the
whole time you know what I don't even
realize when they're on or off anymore
what does that mean cuz you know why
because my my life is that cool okay so
when I have sunglasses on indoors I
don't realize it okay so I want to ask
you something
yo don't do that go ahead shoot ponder
you you are welcome to welcome to fight
or in the kid yes I know crystally is
casting yeah well is it well looks like
Miss su mo first of all your shoes make
you
those are lips obviously they're not
only outside of dude I'm six-two well
they're not they're air maxes dude
you're acting like they're [ __ ] well
and they're gold right there gold yeah
well they're matte they're like you know
the animatics don't go I don't care
because I'm not in the fashion that's
obvious slam you start out with a
[ __ ] Grand Slam not a slam hey man we
got a bunch of [ __ ] specials here at
Denny's but you just wanted the good old
fashioned grand slam fest huh that
wasn't a slam and your mouth is twisted
in such a disrespectful manner be
respectful okay I'm respectful dude I
know what I actually am respectful and
I'll tell you why and I'm gonna take off
my sunglasses because I'm gonna be
respectful here and I'm not a piece of
[ __ ] and why does a non piece of [ __ ] do
comes comes bearing gifts I got you from
a gift from Starbucks not I can't I know
you like this stuff nope I can't eat
that you know why Harry and I have
psoriasis because it's sweet
we're simply strawberry eat that from
Starbucks and I got it for you and now I
drink a black [ __ ] iced americano now
that's as hard as it gets dude and I got
that for you because you're a sweet tart
tart Nash that's why man I got you that
pink [ __ ] simply strawberry it cost
about 450 and that didn't make a [ __ ]
bad
but I got it for you because you're a
sweet heart Hartness do it you [ __ ] I
can't I don't drink it all no I won't
number one I have psoriasis and that
will aggravate my skin number two number
two I don't wouldn't eat this anyway
because I'm a hard dude myself you're
not a hard dude you look cute as showed
that don't take it yeah that's it you
have a pink iPhone case I do because I
wanted to match because I knew I was
coming to see you I change it with every
day I got a pink iPhone case for this
because I know it matches your [ __ ] no
no no because I knew I was coming here
and I want it to match your sweet heart
tartness do it don't say it like that I
don't want this this is a fighter in the
kid anymore this is the the [ __ ] the
the real the Super Deluxe okayed no and
the [ __ ] sweet tart tart nasty no no
hey welcome to the Super Deluxe Oh kid
and the sweet tart turns out the name
you're not gonna rebrand this show that
I've worked so hard to build
alright the [ __ ] is where's the other
guy